hey hey i'm chef amberle you might know
me from food network's worst cooks in
america and i am here today sharing my
pro tips from pro chefs
i can help you
make a delicious quick and easy chicken
paella dinner it is basically a chicken
breast that's opened like a book pounded
flat cooked fast and furious quick and
easy and then topped with whatever you
want to top it with but today what i'm
doing is my super summer chicken pie
yard which is the flash fried chicken
with a watermelon cucumber red onion and
feta cheese salad so we're going to
start off by doing what we call our
mise-en-place the french term for put in
place
need about one cup of diced cucumbers so
we're always when we're thinking of
knife cuts we think slices sticks dices
slices sticks dices so then look at what
i have beautiful knife cuts that are all
the same size
very important in cooking uniformity
then we have some watermelon and i'm
just gonna cut the rind off like that
look at the smile and this is gonna go
right in my thank you for coming bowl
and then i'm going to use this thing one
of my favorite pieces of kitchen
equipment it's called a bench scrape
it's great for transferring things i'm
going to
slice a little bit of a red onion it's
just like this very thin little slices
use the tip of the knife
and slice to the back but not through
the back
so then look at what we have beautifully
sliced red onions i have two kinds of
herbs i have cilantro
i cilantro is one of my favorite herbs
it's bright it's fresh so we're just
gonna give this sort of a coarse chop
so when we're slicing herbs we think
long slices with a sharp knife we don't
want to crash down right on top of this
because we don't want bruised herbs we
want them to maintain their freshness
their integrity and we're going to use
some mint as well
i'm just going to whip together the
little vinaigrette for this i'm going to
use the juice and zest of two limes so
when we're talking about the zest of
citrus
that's the colored part and that
actually is where the big flavor is in
the citrus that's where the citrus oils
are so
if you're not zesting your citrus you're
losing so much so i'm using this tool
which is called a microplane it's a very
fine grater
and we just go a couple little swipes on
each side
just till you get past the colored part
and then we stop and we rotate and we
just get the colored part off of the
whole thing and i'm going to use a
little citrus squeezer thank you for
coming one more
i'm going to put in about a tablespoon
of honey into this we'll give that a
little pinch of salt
there we go so we'll just have this
standing by
so i have a
wet paper towel a damp paper towel and i
have a
uh plastic cutting board that i'm using
for my chicken so like this is all its
own private idaho right here so i have a
knife and i'm going to just lay my hands
flat on this
and i'm going to make a long thin cut to
open this guy up like a book
that is my chicken breast that i have
just opened up now we're going to give
this guy a cover with some plastic wrap
and we're just going to beat our meat a
little bit i mean we're not trying to
tenderize our chicken breast our chicken
is tender already we just want to
flatten it so it's a nice even and very
thin piece of chicken i just use a small
saute pan and i just give it a whack
yeah it's kind of fun
there we go boom now i have a saute pan
here that i'm going to heat up i'm going
to throw a little bit of olive oil in
there extra virgin always
now i'm going to season my chicken
salt
i'm also going to give a little sprinky
dink of granulated garlic as well no
just for fun so remember this is a
really fast cook so you want your pan
really nice and hot like when you put
your chicken in your pan you want to
hear
like rambunctious applause like you want
to hear that sizzle if you don't
wait i always put my oil in my pan and
heat up my pan and oil together once i
see like a little tiny bit of smoke
coming a little tiny bit of smoke coming
off there um
then i know we're ready you see the sort
of little wave and the shimmy
oh yeah did you hear that rambunctious
applause
there we go
when we see the chicken
turning white around the outside edge
then we know it's about ready to turn
over we're gonna cook it about
two-thirds of the way on this first side
and then we're gonna flip it over and
finish cooking it the other way so i see
the outside of my chicken starting to
sort of turn white
but
not ready to turn it over yet
so while my chicken is finishing up
let's just go ahead and get our salad
together
[Music]
so i have my arugula
i have my watermelon let's get that in
there i have my cucumbers
i have my red onion
i have my little vinaigrette
i'm keeping an eye on my chicken look at
me multitasking and i'm not even
stressed out about it
all right look at that
a nice little drizzle of dressing a
little bit of olive oil
there we go we'll toss this around
all right i'm gonna turn my chicken over
now look at that
oh yeah baby that looks good we have a
nice little brown crust on there round
food tastes good
we like that almost all the parts are in
there but what do i need to do i need to
do a little q a little quality control i
mean how do i know if it's delicious
right food should taste good but now
with another little pinch of salt it's
really gonna taste good
all right
chicken just about done
there this chicken's done all right we
put her down on the plate first let's
toss our herbs in there
we're gonna finish up with a little tiny
bit of feta cheese i'm a feta cheese
lover show your people that you're
cooking for some love and there we go
now if you happen to make this recipe
which i so hope you do hit me up on
instagram at chef ann burrell
and of course hashtag the drewberrymore
show and you can find lots more pro-chef
tricks tips and hacks at
thedrewberrymoreshow.com
so
you know make it enjoy it have fun and
we'll see you soon
[Music]
you